vous avez déjà parlé des smartphones de
Motorola plusieurs fois il y a eu le
s-c40 pro il y a pas très longtemps et
là je vais vous parler de leur nouveau
smartphone qui vient se plier le pliant
le pliable comme vous voulez c'est le
Motorola Razer le 40 ultra parce que
Motorola vient de sortir ces nouveaux
smartphones qui se plie pour l'année
2023 et avant il y en avait un
d'ailleurs je vous ai présenté l'année
dernière c'était le Razer 2022 et là il
sort deux modèles très cool dont celui
que j'ai juste ici si vous regardez
c'est le Razer 40
ultra
ultra parce qu'il existe un Razer 40 qui
est déjà cool et qui fait plein de
choses et qui permet d'avoir un
smartphone pliant chez Motorola mais
moins cher et ça c'est bien mais c'est
pas le sujet aujourd'hui le sujet
aujourd'hui c'est de vous parler de
celui-là du Razer 48 ultra qui arrive
dans cette jolie boîte et que je trouve
vraiment intéressant pour plein de
points donc aujourd'hui je vais vous
expliquer ce que peut faire ce Motorola
Razer 40 ultra on va regarder s'il est
fait pour vous on va regarder les points
positifs on va aussi regarder quelques
points négatifs parce qu'il y en a et
c'est parti on y va
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisée en partenariat avec Motorola
Motorola m'a dit Monsieur Gru est-ce que
tu voudrais présenter notre nouveau
smartphone le Razer 48 ultra la réponse
est oui grand oui parce que ça
m'intéresse et que je suis passionné par
la tech alors je sais pas si on remonte
en arrière au début des années 2000 une
période où j'ai vécu ma petite vingtaine
tranquille ou par là et bien Motorola
Resort c'est une des références il faut
savoir que dans les années 2000 ils ont
vendu plus de 130 millions de
smartphones Razer ce qui est énorme et
puis depuis les années 2000 Motorola est
toujours dans la place avec des
smartphones intéressants je vous ai je
vous en ai présenté plusieurs fois et là
ils reviennent avec ce petit truc là et
ce petit truc là c'est quand même
vachement cool parce que si on aime la
tech et si on s'intéresse on connaît les
formats des smartphones qui viennent se
plier comme notamment le Razer qu'on a
vu l'année dernière mais le truc qui
nous propose là je dois reconnaître que
ça ne aille tellement fort vous avez cet
écran là qui vient même englober les
caméras que je trouve ça absolument
dingue et j'adore j'adore pourquoi parce
que l'idée mon smartphone qui vient de
se plier l'idée de la modularité et bien
c'est de pouvoir se servir de son
smartphone lorsqu'il est plié sinon il y
a pas d'intérêt c'est juste pour gagner
de la place et le mettre dans une poche
ok mais il faut venir l'utiliser et si
c'est pas un écran de notification ici
c'est un écran qui a réel intérêt à réel
sens et je trouve ça chouette et c'est
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui l'écran externe
le plus grand du marché je vous montrer
rapidement l'intérieur vous avez aussi
un grand écran lorsque vous venez
l'ouvrir qui est très très sympa vous
avez bien évidemment une charnière qui
tient et qui coule et qui aime bien
maîtriser de la part de Motorola donc ça
ça me plaît mais moi le truc qui me hype
énormément cet écran à l'extérieur parce
qu'il sert vraiment quelque chose et
c'est mon premier point l'écran
extérieur alors cet écran extérieur il
fait 3,6 pouces et duoled et surtout il
a un taux de rafraîchissement qui va
jusqu'à 144 Hz alors 144 Hertz juste
pour regarder comme ça et venir naviguer
ça n'a pas grand intérêt le grand
intérêt c'est pour le jeu pour le gaming
parce que alors regardez vous le voyez
sous les yeux vous avez ici 6 petites
icônes qui correspondent en réalité à 6
raccourcis que vous allez pouvoir avoir
soit en naviguant comme ça soit on
appuie sur le bouton directement avec
votre clavier numérique ici vous arrivez
vos différentes applications vous voyez
alors ce sont des raccourcis vous pouvez
cliquer là hop là pour venir les éditer
et mettre les applications que vous
voulez donc on met vraiment les apps
qu'on veut et les avant qu'on a besoin
donc ça déjà c'est très cool
c'est-à-dire que en un clic PAF vous
avez accès à vos apps favoris donc cette
notion de raccourci elle est là vos
contacts ok votre emploi du temps de la
journée la météo très pratique également
et là il y a plein de petits jeux et ça
c'est le truc qui me fait vraiment
marrer pourquoi parce que j'ai passé
beaucoup de temps dessus et j'ai un coup
de cœur tout particulier pour stack
Bones qui a un jeu que je trouve juste
très cool et en fait c'est un peu dans
dans l'idée des jeux du comme le snake
qu'on avait avant vous avez connu le
snake en fait là vous laissez appuyer
vous descendez tac tac tac tac bien côté
qui est super sympa avec ce jeu hop là
voyez tac je pète des carrés je descends
et c'est très très très très
satisfaisant personnellement hop là
j'adore quand j'attends la barre
d'énergie plat tout pète ça se termine
c'est beau j'ai passé beaucoup de temps
alors on se dirait ok 144 Hertz pour ces
petits jeux il y a-t-il vraiment en
intérêt la réponse est peut-être non
mais en tout cas j'aime beaucoup et
alors ce qui est cool et vous le voyez
sur les jeux que vous avez là il y en a
9 aujourd'hui vous pouvez trouver là
comme ça dans les combien j'en ai 9 en
tout normalement alors vous pouvez en
avoir d'autres en plus ici il y a
également un compagnon de vie qui va
arriver qui va suivre votre rythme en
fonction de l'heure et qui s'appelle mou
et puis ensuite vous avez votre
actualité ici alors cet écran extérieur
bien évidemment et bien il vous montre
ses petites raccourcis et ses usages
comme ça mais toi qui est aussi cool
c'est l'appareil photo alors l'appareil
photo pour venir l'utiliser vous allez
soit ici dans votre module appareil
photo et là vous avez votre appareil
photo tel qu'il est là je vais vous le
montrer dans quelques instants ou alors
il y a un autre que nous a fait Motorola
ici qui est cool vous prenez votre main
vous le tournez deux fois votre
smartphone et ça vous ouvre l'appareil
photo vous pouvez prendre une photo soit
en appuyant directement sur l'écran et
hop là vous avez fait la photo vous
voyez j'ai une belle tronche ici soit
directement en appuyant sur le bouton de
volume sur le côté vous prenez vous
déclenchez ces pratiques et vous pouvez
également prendre une photo avec la
pomme de votre main alors le bon sens on
prend les photos c'est comme ça et non
pas dans l'autre sens est-ce que vous
dit Motorola après ça marche d'un côté
et l'autre à vous de voir faites ce que
vous voulez donc ça c'est cool alors
vous avez ce mode photo comme ça et vous
avez plein d'autres modes et surtout que
je trouve intéressant c'est que lui X
est vraiment bien fait photo mode
portrait bon ok on va faire des photos
en mode portrait on peut le faire ici
vous avez également un mode miroir avec
un effet qui est assez rigolo vas-y
c'est voyez votre encadrement donc là ça
me fait un petit à côté sur le côté
là je suis quand même avec hop là en
mode Motorola et donc là ok une fois de
plus c'est assez assez rigolo donc ce
petit model là il est assez marrant et
il y a plein de petites options qui sont
assez cool hop là j'appuie là pour le
faire apparaître vous voyez je peux
changer bref il y a des petits trucs un
peu marrant là-dessus ça c'est cool mode
vidéo photo portrait série de photos
série de photos ça vous fait plein de
photos c'est un photoboot en fait comme
lorsque vous êtes dans les cabines vous
savez c'était de votre photo là vous en
fait si je crois donc vous êtes toutes
vos petites photos bon ok j'en ai assez
fait ça me suffit donc ça c'est marrant
et une fois de plus c'est très pratique
d'avoir ce grand écran comme ça qui vous
permet de tout avoir sous la main donc
ça je trouve ça vraiment bien parce que
Motorola vient vraiment utiliser tous
l'espace ici extérieur dont on a besoin
donc il y a un réel intérêt donc je suis
vachement happé par ça on peut en plus
dire tout personnaliser venir
personnaliser son écran de fond le
changer personnaliser la police je vous
montre comment elle est assez loin ici
ça c'est très très cool en plus sur le
haut et bien vous avez toutes vos
options d'Android qui sont ici donc ça
c'est bien pour venir paramétrer votre
smartphone utiliser facilement ça c'est
cool et puis sur le bas vous avez vos
notifications et pour avoir accès une
notification pour en plus venir cliquer
juste ici vous cliquez vous avez les
notifications et là vous cliquez juste
ici là et vous avez accès à votre niveau
de batterie qu'une fois de plus est bien
vu bien pensé et luux est tellement bien
pensé ici vraiment j'adore alors après
quand on l'ouvre on a un écran à
l'intérieur et ça c'est plutôt cool et
c'est là où il a 2e bonne surprise c'est
qu'en fait sous le doigt vous ne sentez
quasiment rien ça c'est du gras ça c'est
charnière que vous allez avoir ici et à
la façon dont elle est conçue par
Motorola il fait qu'en fait ça va pas
venir pincer votre écran et que vous ne
sentez quasiment rien sur le doigt
personnellement j'adore rester un grand
écran P o LED 6,9 pouces et là vous avez
un taux de rafraîchissement qui va
monter jusqu'à 165 Hertz c'est à dire
que vous avez du 144 Hertz devant 165
Hertz à l'intérieur c'est juste
démentiel et c'est un smartphone qui est
très très bien spécifique après vous
allez dans vos paramètres et dans votre
affichage vous pouvez venir le modifier
si vous le souhaitez taux de
rafraîchissement il est mis sur élevé et
voyez il va monter jusqu'à 165 Hertz de
façon intelligente sinon 60 r sensation
qu'ici en plus c'est une tal ltpo au
lieu d'entrer d'un côté un petit peu
technique ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que ça permet d'aller sur une résolution
qui part de 1r c'est à dire pour un
always on display jusqu'à 165 Hertz et
en fait votre smartphone il va venir
afficher le nom d'image dont vous avez
besoin par rapport aux applications que
vous allez utiliser donc ça c'est malin
et c'est vraiment bien vu et ce qui est
cool et qu'en plus ici c'est quand même
malgré tout solide ils nous ont mis cinq
couches de verre qu'on va avoir ici
extrêmement résistant et rassurant
également il y a un autre point que
j'aime bien c'est que comme vous avez un
écran 22/9 et bien si par exemple je
vais me remettre un petit Obi-Wan Kenobi
et bien on est totalement adapté sur ce
format ici sur Disney plus vous voyez
c'est vraiment un format qui est très
très long en fait de base et là je peux
voir dézoomer je suis déjà dézoomer au
max alors je peux venir zoomer un petit
peu plus si je veux perds pas énormément
donc pour tout ce qui va être format
cinémascope sur les formats un petit peu
longs très clairement ça marche et ça
c'est très très bien maintenant le point
qui m'a assez bluffé c'est l'audio
pourquoi et bien parce que vous avez des
haut-parleurs stéréo ici et ici je
trouve que l'expérience audio est
vraiment bien regardez il y a vraiment
du sport il y a un petit déséquilibre
droite-gauche bien évidemment mais tout
ça une fois de plus vraiment bien fait
ici de la part de Motorola donc si vous
voulez regarder du contenu c'est très
très bon alors attention lorsque vous
mettez trop fort ça sature donc vous
baissez légèrement vous maîtrisez mais
ça conviendra et pour moi là-dessus
aussi c'est un point fort donc pour tout
ce qui va être multimédia film série
pour tout ce qui va être gaming avec ce
auto de rafraîchissement à 165 Hertz sur
l'écran intérieur et 144s sur l'écran
extérieur et bien vous avez un
smartphone qui va être très bon pour
tout ce qui va être divertissement film
série gaming sans aucun problème tout en
sachant que ce smartphone existe dans
trois couleurs soit en noir alors le
seul truc un peu négatif c'est que il
prend quand même pas mal les traces de
doigts donc vous venez le nettoyer avec
une petite chiffonnette ici il existe en
noir comme il est là j'aime bien vous
avez un noir mat au dos donc là il y a
pas de trace de doigts c'est vraiment
sur l'écran vous allez traces de doigts
donc en noir comme ça il existe en bleu
et comme ils ont un partenariat avec
Pantone vous avez également la couleur
de l'année le Viva magenta de Pantone
donc si vous voulez un truc un peu plus
flashy et bien vous l'aurez une fois de
plus si ce smartphone vous intéresse
vous met tous les liens en bas dans la
description et je vous le disais il y a
un point qui pour moi est important ici
c'est la personnalisation qu'on va avoir
alors le capteur d'empreinte digitale
vous posez votre doigt ça déverrouille
très très rapidement vous venez
complètement personnaliser ici votre
smartphone par exemple les fonds d'écran
il y en a énormément pour mettre des
dynamiques par exemple venir les
télécharger il y en a un paquet stylisez
également pour dire St une photo hop là
faire des petits effets si je souhaite
bon à vous de voir vous prendre des
photos que vous voulez là je suis pas
convaincu de la proposition mais si vous
voulez c'est complètement possible des
sélections d'images il y a énormément
d'images qu'on peut venir mettre moi
j'ai mis un thème son pour mettre un
thème clair également si on le souhaite
donc si on des différents besoins on
peut changer le fond d'écran et je vous
l'ai dit il y en a énormément des
paysages bref de tous les côtés pour
échanger la taille de police moi je l'ai
augmenté légèrement et de police non pas
que j'ai des problèmes de vue mais que
je trouve que c'est plus joli ici
d'avoir des icônes un poil plus gros
c'est une police un peu plus grosse que
ce que on avait d'origine vous voyez on
peut quand même aller assez loin et se
faire plaisir ici avec ce smartphone
l'autre point qui est intéressant c'est
qu'ils ont fait un partenariat avec
Spotify par exemple je vais vous mettre
un petit peu de musique sans mettre les
Guns donc lorsque je suis en train
d'écouter de la musique voyez hop là
j'ai le smartphone fermé j'ai
directement ici alors il y a pas mal de
reflets et bien les Guns ici je peux
venir changer de morceau si je le
souhaite donc ça c'est quand même très
très cool voyez par exemple là je peux
venir ajouter ensuite Spotify ici
lorsque j'ai ajouté Spotify après je
peux déplacer music one je laisse
appuyer je peux le déplacer le mettre où
je veux très facilement et ensuite je
peux venir l'ouvrir ici directement et
ce qui est cool c'est que Motorola est
travailler avec Spotify pour
complètement adapter l'interface sur ce
petit écran là donc une fois de plus
c'est pas un écran de notification c'est
un écran qui a un réel usage et je
trouve ça juste très très cool et
lorsque j'éteins vous voyez et bien je
vais retrouver mon Spotify ici au lieu
d'avoir mon écran d'accueil et si j'ai
fermé Spotify après bien voyez je
retrouverai mon écran d'accueil ici avec
mon horloge alors il y a plein de styles
différents horloge j'ai mis celui-là
mais il y en a énormément et ça pour
venir le personnaliser également vous
venez ici vous allez dans écran externe
et dans écran externe vous avez pas mal
de possibilités donc l'horloge il y en a
pas mal voyez vous avez différents choix
en fonction de ce que vous allez aimer
et si ça c'est pratique le fond d'écran
également de l'écran externe et très
cool donc il y a pas mal de possibilités
personnellement j'ai mis la baleine elle
me plaît énormément et pano les grilles
la météo pour venir rajouter d'autres
choses vous pouvez rajouter Google fit
si vous voulez bon bah je l'ai pas mis
mais pas mal de choses la taille de
police qu'on peut venir agrandir moi je
l'agrandis je vous l'ai dit les
paramètres de l'application l'agenda les
alertes d'urgence bref il y en a
beaucoup beaucoup les aperçus direct les
Paramètres d'appel bref un écran externe
qui sert énormément on peut totalement
venir customiser personnellement j'adore
alors après il y a un truc à venir
regarder et bien c'est ces deux petites
caméras que vous allez avoir ici un
grand angle de 12 mégapixels que bref
1.5 dual pixel et avec une super
stabilisation pour venir faire des
vidéos vous l'avez déjà montré lorsque
je parlais du Edge 40 ultra c'est
l'horizon Lock qui marche bien qui est
très cool vous avez également un capteur
ultra grand-angle et macro de 13
mégapixels sans oublier une caméra à
l'intérieur on l'oublie assez souvent
ici c'est la caméra de selfie ici de 32
mégapixels le truc intéressant avec le
smartphone c'est que lorsque vous voulez
faire des photos et bien vous pouvez le
poser comme ça et ça servira un peu en
mode tripode donc lorsque je veux
déclencher et bien mon appareil photo je
peux venir cliquer juste là et là hop là
vous allez vous voir et si je passe à
l'intérieur ensuite je me vois donc là
vous voyez plus moi je me vois et je
clique là vous vous voyez alors après il
y a un autre petit mode qui est assez
cool c'est des animations et des
animations extérieur lorsque moi je me
mets vraiment en face vous voyez là je
vais mettre comme ça qui va me donner je
sais pas si pour me donner des idées de
sourire à faire voilà de tronche que je
peux venir faire pour venir faire des
photos donc le truc est assez marrant
tout ça c'est rigolo et lorsqu'il
reconnaît plus quelqu'un en face il le
désactive mais une fois de plus vous
voulez prendre quelqu'un en photo
personne peut se voir vous voulez vous
vous filmer vous pouvez vous voir je ne
mets comme ça tag je me vois très très
facilement donc là je vais en voir je
suis en train de me regarder donc je
trouve ça vachement cool donc là hop là
là vous voyez là je me vois vous voyez
je me vois donc moi je trouve ça
extrêmement malin et surtout une fois de
plus le sexe ça vient de prendre tous
l'écran extérieur après l'application
Photos c'est un très grand classique
photo portrait vidéo vous avez la macro
là vous pouvez venir monter jusqu'à un
zoom qui va pas très loin qui va jusqu'à
x 8 vous allez voir qu'on est rapidement
limité mais une fois de plus cet écran
externe un vrai usage et ça c'est
chouette j'adore ce smartphone pour tout
ce qu'on peut venir en faire notamment
avec l'écran externe et je vous le dis
une fois de plus j'adore j'adore j'adore
énormément mais il y a deux points un
petit peu négatif ici le premier ça va
être la photo puisque les photos que
vous avez sont pas mal mais peu faire
mieux je vous montre sur le capteur
principal là vous voyez ça fonctionne
bien les zones d'ombre sont bien
respectées les ombres de pleine lumière
également sont respectées le ciel est
bien on va bien le fond tout est bien
tout est bien tout est joli ultra grand
temps on perd un peu en précision mais
c'est pas déconnant on peut venir se
rapprocher x 2 là déjà voyez au niveau
du ciel on a un peu plus de mal c'est un
zoom numérique ça c'est un X 8 le max
que je peux avoir alors là c'est pareil
ça marche quand même plutôt pas mal dans
l'ensemble l'ultra grand angle un peu
moins précis globalement ça fait le taf
donc globalement c'est pas mauvais même
avec un contre-jour comme ça le soleil
en pleine tronche ça fonctionne mais je
trouve qu'il y a des petits moments
c'est un peu plus dur lorsque vous voyez
par exemple venir photographier ici des
fleurs le contour va légèrement baver
ici et ça je trouve que c'est un poil
dommage là sur l'ultra grand-angle
couleur ça vient de ressortir au niveau
du ciel sont pas très naturel et ça fait
un espèce de détourage un peu bizarre et
là au niveau des branches c'est pareil
ça marche pas donc il y a un truc qui
est un peu arbit ici d'un point de vue
logiciel la macro bon bah la macro pas
grand chose à dire le taf est
globalement à peu près fait pas évident
de trouver la bonne distance mais c'est
pas mauvais donc ici rien à dire le fait
de le mettre en mode trépied je trouve
ça bien donc là j'avais posé en mode
trépied vous voyez je me prends en photo
coucou toi je le tiens aussi à la main
pour voir ça marche bien ça déclenche et
en mode selfie pour le coup ça marche
vraiment bien et aucun problème avec ça
le mode portrait aussi est très correct
de déclencher voyez alors il a un petit
peu de mal ici là j'ai l'impression là
vous voyez c'est un peu moins précis il
y a eu un peu plus de mal mais
globalement le boulot il fait est-ce que
j'aime pas particulièrement c'est la
caméra que vous avez à l'intérieur là
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a un voile sur
l'image puis le deuxième point que je
vais un peu regretter c'est que je
trouve que cette partie extérieure du
smartphone va venir chauffer c'est à
dire que lorsque je l'ai alors
normalement j'utilise comme ça l'écran
externe je touche que lorsque je suis en
train de naviguer dessus mais je trouve
que ça chauffe alors voyez c'est assez
marrant petit point de détail je vous le
montre je voulais pas montrer tout à
l'heure lorsque j'ai mis Spotify là bien
voyez hop là j'ai mon horloge je vais là
j'ai Spotify et ça une fois de plus d'un
point de vue logiciel c'est juste fou et
il faut regarder juste là là vous voyez
j'ai pas l'heure et lorsque je décale
j'ai l'heure qui apparaît puisque
lorsque je suis sur Spotify j'ai plus
l'heure donc je veux connaître l'heure
j'ai l'heure qui est là donc ça c'est
pareil d'un point de vue ui c'est juste
magnifique mais je regrette que lorsque
je prends mon smartphone comme ça et
bien j'ai vraiment cette partie en haut
qui va venir chauffer alors est-ce que
j'ai mon processeur qui est là à savoir
que j'ai le sein dragon 8 plus Jane 1 il
y a des meilleurs processeurs soyons
clairs aujourd'hui qui chauffent pas
particulièrement mais peut-être qu'au
niveau de la conception il va se trouver
juste en dessous et là on sent que ça
chauffe soyons clair ça normalement sur
ce genre de smartphone également vous
avez la batterie qui est coupé en deux
il est batterie de 3800 milliampères
heure avec une partie de la batterie qui
va être là et l'autre partie qui va être
là pour permettre effectivement et bien
d'avoir de la finesse donc une vraie
répartition donc là j'ai pas de chauffe
vraiment pas mais ici j'en ai un petit
peu lorsque je l'utilise si vous
craignez pas d'avoir un peu de chauffe
pas de problème alors après soyons
clairs on se brûle pas les doigts donc
il y a aucun problème là-dessus mais je
le sens un peu et si vous craignez ce
côté-là ça peut légèrement être
inconfortable mais légèrement
l'autonomie n'est pas mauvaise elle une
très grosse batterie je vous laisse du
3800 maheur c'est pas énormément mais ça
permet de tenir la journée sans problème
toute façon le stade dragon 8 plus gène
1 n'est pas très énergivore donc bon
globalement ça fonctionne et puis après
l'autre point positif c'est que vous
avez quand même votre blog de charge qui
inclut avec un bloc de charge ici de 30
watts que vous avez directement avec
votre smartphone donc ça c'est cool et
si vous souhaitez le recharger en
induction pour le recharger jusqu'à 5
watts sans fil et petit détail en plus
sachez que avec votre boîte et bien vous
avez une coque de protection qui incite
donc ici pas de souci pas de galère ça
c'est bien aussi petit point de détail
pour les technophiles vous avez 8 Go de
RAM plus 256 Go de stockage et si non
extensible mais globalement vraiment il
y a de quoi faire et vous avez en plus
de la RAM virtuelle si vous souhaitez en
profiter vous pouvez le faire vous
pouvez monter un petit peu la RAM
virtuellement la charnière en plus est
bien et se tient bien donc c'est vrai
c'est pareil c'est un point qui est
positif alors on va pas le mettre comme
ça soyons clair et lorsque vous le
mettez comme ça pour venir vous filmer
vous pouvez le faire sans problème vous
avez en plus d'un point de vue purement
logiciel aussi ce petit mode qui est pas
mal qui fait que lorsque vous venez le
plier comme ça et bien vous voyez cette
partie du haut va remonter là vous êtes
toute une partie de commande donc c'est
une fois de plus bien pensé vous avez
une carte SIM plus une sim si vous le
souhaitez du wifi 6e et le ready for qui
permet de connecter votre smartphone un
moniteur à une télé et à l'utiliser sans
fil vous pouvez rajouter un clavier et
une souris et utiliser votre smartphone
comme un petit ordinateur ça c'est une
option qui est assez pratique et qui est
bien chez Motorola qui est plus destiné
à une flotte professionnelle mais
au-delà de ça c'est un smartphone que
j'aime beaucoup pourquoi et bien parce
que sur ce format de smartphone qui
vient se plier vous avez cet écran qui
est tellement beau tellement bien pensé
donc si vous voulez un smartphone pliant
pliable comme vous voulez une fois de
plus avec un grand écran
utile à l'extérieur de votre smartphone
avec plein d'applications des raccourcis
une expérience logiciel maîtrisée très
bien pensée et bien le Motorola Razer
Razer Razer on va dire Razer c'est pas
plus sexy 40 ultra peu globalement être
chez vous au tarif de 1199 euros alors
tout en sachant que vous avez une offre
de lancement du premier juin jusqu'au 16
juillet c'est assez long quand même ça
passe vite donc globalement allez-y s'il
vous intéresse je vous le mets le lien
en bas dans la description et bien vous
avez une Lenovo Tab 11 plus offert qui
normalement coûte la nous sommes de 279
euros donc ça c'est quand même plutôt
cool et si une fois de plus ce
smartphone vous intéresse vous avez les
liens en bas dans la description donc
personnellement je suis super content de
voir venir Motorola avec cette copie cet
écran externe cette charnière qui est
sympa et qui tient bien ce smartphone
que je trouve cool alors après je
voulais dire il y a deux petits points
qu'on peut venir regarder ça va être le
fait qu'il chauffe légèrement si c'est
pas un souci pour vous ça fonctionnera
et puis les photos qui sont pas
mauvaises mais un peu en dessous de ce
qu'on pourrait attendre sur un
smartphone de ce tarif là mais
globalement l'expérience est tellement
bien réussi d'un point de vue logiciel
je peux que dire bravo à Motorola et une
fois de plus si vous intéresse vous
pouvez y aller sans aucun problème voilà
donc dites-moi ce que vous en pensez ce
qu'il vous intéresse oui non quoi
comment ce smartphone de Motorola se
rase Razer 40 ultra marquez moi ça en
bas dans les commentaires et nous on se
retrouve bien évidemment bientôt pour
continuer à parler tech de Motorola et
d'autre voilà je vous embrasse prenez
soin de vous et à bientôt Ciao